oui bien sûr bien sûr qu'il a commis une
erreur bien sûr qu'il a commis une
erreur sa place était là qu'est-ce qu'il
a dit il a dit attendez j'avais j'avais
noté des choses sur ce qu'il dit il dit
il faut l'unité des Français il faut un
message d'humanité et c'était quoi hier
c'était quoi hier c'était pas un message
d'unité c'était pas un message
d'humanité bien sûr que sa place elle
étit là mais je pense qu'il a commis une
erreur peut-être qu'il est il est mal
conseillé peut-être j'espère que c'est
pas un certain nombre de gens qui lui
ont dit oui vous rappelez on pensait
qu'il y aurait moins de gens que ça que
qui a un certain nombre de de gens
autour de lui qui disent ah oui mais
enfin attendez si vous êtes là et qu'il
y a pas trop de monde c'est pas bien
pour votre image non il aurait dû être
là il aurait dû être là il faut qu'il
fasse attention Emmanuel Macron et moi
je suis pas un
antimacroniste systématique évidemment
pas mais même là il aurait dû être là
comme il devrait faire attention à ce
qu'il dit vous avez vu un jour il exige
un jour il y a de jours il parle qu'il
faut à la BBC qu'il faut arrêter les
bomb ement et 2 jours après il dit oui
non mais moi je je j'ai pas voulu dire
tout à fait ça il faut évidemment que
que Israël gagne sur le Hamas comment
vous voulez gagner sur le Hamas sans
faire la guerre au Hamas il faut
m'expliquer comment comment vous gagnez
une guerre sans faire de bombardement
honnêtement ça tient pas la
route